[Music]
since 2013 the founders of the group
give tribe have been collecting teddy
bears
after losing a loved one from heart
failure they've made it their mission to
collect hundreds of teddy bears each
year to donate
to the children's heart foundation and
they need our help
with casey's cause and joining me to
tell us more is little nino galloway the
co-founder
of [ __ ] tribe hello little nino tell us
more
what is casey's cause so
casey's cause is a foundation that i
made in kindergarten
to honor my papa since he died from
heart disease and we're going to get
stuffed
animals every year and donate it to the
children's heart foundation on june
1st which is my papa's birthday that is
amazing your papa sounds like
he was an amazing man tell us why this
means so much to you
this means so much to me because i
he died when i was very young so i don't
have
much to remember of him and this helps
me remember him and what a way
for his legacy to go on tell us about
the donations
where do they go exactly
so they go to maggie's garden and the
children's heart foundation
and this is all to cheer up kids when
they're
going into surgery how does this work
so it helps kids because they get a
stuffed animal and helps them know that
they are loved by other people and
recognized
wow i and you came up with this all on
your own what a great kid
now tell us where do we go to donate how
do we donate
what exactly are you looking for
so you can go to givetribe.com to donate
and you can either
donate um a teddy bear at one of our
locations which is
the fire north las vegas fire department
on 2626 i think it's east cary avenue
or you can go to our office and if you
don't have time to do that
you can donate a few some money on our
website and then we'll go and buy a sub
a stuffed animal on your name how long
have you been doing this
i've been doing this since kindergarten
which was
2014 or 15. and now you're you're
getting ready to wrap up sixth grade
right
yep that is so great if you could say
one more thing to the people out there
about donating what would you tell them
i would say this is needed more now than
ever
thank you so much little nino you are a
joy
please come on anytime we appreciate it
and please
give if you can jc i'll send it over to
you